why shouldn't the people that are buying
these weapons be well trained
why shouldn't there be something tied to
mental health and the the medication
they're taking
why shouldn't that be okay for us to
know that what's wrong with knowing that
and what's wrong with us
increasing training when i get a car
that i use i got to get a permit and i
got to get a license right i mean that's
across the board and
a car is a weapon the car some believe
me there's some drivers in america
shouldn't be driving any cars right now
right so why not focus on training
and is there anybody that's buying guns
that shouldn't have access to those guns
by the way fyi keep in mind i know that
no matter what we do we're not gonna get
to zero percent where none of this
stuff's going to be happening but why
not focus on getting people trained more
tom you build a great point my daughter
just got her driver's license she had to
certify she's not under medication she
has to take a vision test and so it says
on your uh driver's license corrected so
she's pulled over and she doesn't have
glass no her eyesight's fine but if she
had glasses and she's pulled over not
wearing her glasses the cop will say hey
you've got corrected vision why aren't
you wearing your glasses so they do that
and by the way
it's a very elaborate check i've seen it
with my own eyes here in florida you're
76 years old and you go to renew your
driver's license you have to go in there
and you you have to
pass a vision check so
look we require people to go to dmv
bring a registration in you know you
sold your truck to me we fill it out and
i get it
okay
and we have situations where i have to
go to driver's ed and my first time i
have to take a driver's test don't i
to get my driver's license so why not
why not do so why not do this for pat
i'm with you why not do it for guns so
hang on
when you get your first weapon yeah you
have to get a gun safety course if you
want to drive a school bus you have to
get a class c driver's license to be
trained so that you're capable of
driving a bus so why not do the same
thing that your first weapon your gun
license involves training i'm with you a
hundred percent on point i think we
might be on the same page on this my
concern is who gets to a decide the
criteria on that and if it's the federal
government that's incredibly concerning
um there was a boyfriend loophole in a
recent red flag legislation that was
being drafted
and what's to say just hypothetical
scenario playing devil's advocate what
if you are really pissed off at your
boyfriend and
because he cheated on you whatever it
might be and he owns a firearm he owns
an ar-15 and you go and tell the cops
that he's a deranged person and he did
all this stuff and then they go and take
the weapon away there's a very fine line
when it comes to
what government's authority is
on
on being able to decide who owns a
firearm based on our second amendment
americans
all
can
and so where where is that where does
that play i don't know i don't have to
but to make make a point here i want to
make sure that i'm not wrong
in the red flag laws they don't seize
and take the weapon away for you forever
right it's like having your car
impounded hey
we're concerned here so we're gonna
impound your gun
and there's a process to go get it back
was it really a fight here were you
really upset or you're really a risk to
people and there's a process there
that's the point for the red flag now i
agree with what you say because the
people that are against uh background
checks for all weapons you don't know
what they're going to do they're going
to have a list of everybody that owns
every gun right and then they're slowly
going to start classifying every gun as
an assault weapon this is an assault
weapon suddenly a 12-gauge shotgun
that's only used to shoot birds is now
going to be assault weapon and uncle
harry is going to lose his bird gun if
they're just going to keep turning that
knob down because their goal is to is to
get the weapons away from you that is
the argument that comes from the other
side tyler pushback push back on what
i'm saying okay first of all i don't
know where in the country you can't
you can legally buy a weapon without a
going through a
concealed firearms course
what are you talking about in texas you
you you want to talk about how long it
took excuse me there are there are 24
states now that constitutional carry but
you still cannot buy a weapon without
going through a background check you
cannot buy a weapon if you're addicted
to any drugs you cannot buy a weapon if
you have a felony they do an extensive
background check on you and again this
isn't the problem the problem is not the
the law abiding citizen who's buying the
weapon chicago cook county has the
strictest gun laws in the country and
their shootings are skyrocketing they
have 30 40 50 people a week dying
from shootings that are being shot young
kids uh gang members etc etc etc and
again it doesn't matter how strict the
gun laws are if you take the guns away
if somebody wants to do harm they'll do
harm right they'll create a bomb go bomb
a marathon they'll drive a truck through
a christmas parade in wakutia wisconsin
or in france 84 people died on bastille
day this was like 10 years ago in france
they'll drive a truck through the crowd
to catalina's point
people are going to want to do harm the
problem is not the gun it's the
the hedonism and the lack of
of as you put it earlier the lack of god
within the country people people don't
have no you're talking to a guy
you're talking to a guy that loves
america like you wouldn't believe you're
talking to a guy that was in a military
who thinks
i you know how many people i want to
have guns in america you know how many
people i want to have guns in uh
semi-automatics in america how many do
you think i want to have all of them i
want a 100 but 100 percent trained
is what i want 100
trained is what i want let me read you a
couple comments that we just got here on
what i said some agree some disagree
uh uh uh so john mcguire just gave 50
bucks this is common factor amongst the
shooters lonely delusional complete lack
of purpose or belonging
it's uh really hard that
is it really hard to help these kids
let's stop trying to treat the symptom
and go after the cause mentor and give
these kids a purpose fine this next
person said anna bruner said i'm an nra
instructor and i totally agree with pat
on training everyone who owns a firearm
should be trained i've been teaching for
30 years i feel this is the best
solution all i'm saying is
go back and think about you know second
amendment what is second amendment it's
not a privilege right some guy commented
saying it's not a privilege owning a car
is a privilege owning a gun is
constitutional right you have the right
to have this totally get it right
but to me
even if you go back and think about back
in the days where you were worried about
somebody attacking you or even somebody
invading like government somebody comes
into your house and give me this give me
that which happens all the time in a lot
of different countries to make sure that
doesn't happen in america well how do
you fight against that
you'll fight against that against by
knowing how to use these weapons if you
don't know how to use these weapons
you just buy a gun to buy a gun that
doesn't mean you know what you're doing
so to train them is the solution if if
if i again go back to policies
if i want my state to be protected i
want to make my guys more trained but at
the same time i don't want somebody who
is taking
certain mental health medication
to have access to weapons because
they're going through something that is
a concern that we ought to think about
that okay there is a challenge with that
some people fight back on that i totally
understand that argument but i'm trying
to go to the point of what's wrong with
having every single person that owns a
gun be trained what's wrong with that
nothing you talk to the people in the
gun community what's the first thing
they tell you to do train gun safety
yeah that's all they tell you to because
it doesn't matter if you own a weapon
just because you magically conservatives
took that position though what if
conservatives took that position
no what if conservatives said
here's what we want to do let's create
training let's make our guys better by
the way that's another opportunity for
conservatives to get a new audience
there are a lot of groups uh non-profits
that are going to inner cities like
chicago and baltimore and they're
training the communities the the the
youth of the communities on proper gun
safety which i think is a really
interesting point but i love this quote
it was in a it was from
drivefiretrainingcards.com
guns are designed to project kinetic
force at a distance what you do with
them is a reflection of your intent not
the intent of the gun
so
we can train a million what you're
saying with that i i get what you're
saying with that and i agree
um
i don't think this is a
one point solution i think it's ten
point solution it's not only one thing
that's going to fix it all the one out
of 10 that i think is being trained if
you're trained a little bit more i feel
better about it if you're not so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]